[Music]
john is with us john's in reno nevada hi
john how are you
doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
so i know you say never buy a new car um
i'm in a bit of a unique situation no i
say never buy a new car do you have a
million dollar net worth
so i've been wanting to get a truck for
a while um i have a pre-order
reservation for a rivien truck which is
this electric truck coming on the market
yeah um because i put a reservation in a
while ago my reservation price is like
seventy eight thousand current price is
now a hundred thousand
um i'm wondering if i should be
considering buying this truck um below
twenty twenty percent below msrp or if i
should get something used like a tacoma
or a ranger for about half the price
i'll be paying cash for either i want to
get your thoughts what's your net worth
uh
about five to 600k
you should buy a used car
all right
you know why
because
new cars go down in value particularly
brand
new
the next delorean
which this riven may be
i don't think it's the next ford or
chevy
it might be the next tesla which would
be a good thing for you but it could be
the next delorean you know what a
delorean is right
oh yeah the car in back to the future
greatest car and movie history dave yeah
it's also not made anymore
that's true it's it's now a prop yeah
and so you know i don't know what's
gonna happen these trucks i have no idea
i'm not an expert on that uh but you're
you know not only are you buying a brand
new truck not but you're also buying an
electric truck which is a
cutting edge thing and you're gonna buy
a brand that is a brand new brand
and it's in its infancy and we have no
freaking idea what the value this thing
is going to be five years from today
and so you can't afford to take a hit
that's 50 grand when you only have a
half you're going to lose 10 percent of
your net worth screwing around with an
electric truck
maybe
maybe not but maybe
um
normally cars go in half in four years
normal cars do from msrp
and so if this thing maintains a normal
pattern
uh
not worse than normal i i'm predicting i
think you've got a high probability of
worse than normal but if it maintains a
normal pattern
then um
you know i just don't
yeah so
uh no i wouldn't do it but but you're
gonna do it
uh you already knew what we're gonna say
for you called
and so you're gonna do it
but i wouldn't
and there's my reasoning
yeah well he called you and asked you
gave him a formula and you got the
chuckle i had picture in his head going
back it was a chuckle like
yeah
cause he's going he's going hey but
there's a reason why you have that
formula there's a reason why the
percentage that you apply to them that's
what i want people to get if you if you
it's i mean i
it's a math thing right you know when
you lose your butt
on stuff and you only have one but
it's
it's a problem you know that's one way
looking at it you know when you when you
lose 50 grand and you only have 500 000
to your name yeah that's a lot of money
it's depreciating you're losing you got
too many things going the wrong way
while you're trying to build wealth yeah
and that's straight up consumption
is what it is and there's nothing wrong
with consumption there's nothing wrong
with having a toy and if you want to
spend your money on that truck that's
fine
i mean a buddy of mine just bought one
of those things and i hadn't gotten a
ride in it yet but um you know and i i'm
not going to get one that's not my taste
but that doesn't get anything to do with
it but
the point is my buddy the guy that
bought it he's worth about 15 million
dollars yeah if the battery catches fire
like a tesla and just burns the thing to
the ground it isn't going to kill him as
long as he's not in it i mean he's not
going to bother him financially he could
take whatever 100 000 bucks out in the
backyard and burn it and it doesn't
he's got 10 million it's but but when
you only got a half a million and you're
you know you got a probability a high
probability of losing at least 50 000
bucks
then that's why i tell people not to buy
new cars when
because they go down in value like a
rock